éric martel bonjourbonjour centrale de
beauharnois qui est une des plus
importantes de votre raison dans le fond
ici absolument ce une centrale
historique construit pendant la dernière
crise économique en 29 là dedans les
années 29 alors avec des moyens plus
rudimentaires qu'est ce qu'on a
aujourd'hui
mais kate une centrale importante parce
que elle nous permet la majorité de
l'électricité produite presque tout est
exporté à l'extérieur de la province
dont l'exportation va en parler dans une
seconde mais d'abord dans les premiers
cours d'économie ce qu'on apprend la
probité de soutiennent versité c'est
quand il ya une situation de surplus
quant à l'offre dépasse la demande les
prix baissent vous êtes 200 vous
augmentez ce presque sept ports soeur de
deux ans pourquoi cette loi là ça
fonctionne pas pour une rock'n'roll
c'est une excellente question
voyez-vous les prévisions d'énergie de
demandes aux besoins énergétiques de du
québec en électricité sont fait très
longtemps à l'avancé
les besoins ont été faits peut-être ya
10-15 ans moi je travaille sur un plan
stratégique avec mon équipe présentement
on est tenté d'en reparler de l'année
2035 jusqu'à 2300 alors pour nous c'est
important de comprendre par ses
décisions à long terme
alors on a des surplus énergétique
aujourd'hui parce qu'il ya une crise
économique en 2008 qui au fait qu'on a
eu un ralentissement de notre croissance
la demande énergétique alors aussi
ramassé avec des shows plus pour
répondre à votre question c'est clair
que ces surplus aujourd'hui nous on doit
si on les consomme pas ça devient
problématique on doit trouver les moyens
de les consommer le plus possible et
exemple l'exportation c'est important
alors on réussit à les vendre à
l'exportation le plus possible mais les
surplus pourquoi il n'a qu'à jeunes pas
une baisse de prix comme dans un marché
libre parce que les surplus sont établis
vous savez on travaille avec la régie de
l'énergie pour établir nos tarifs selon
nos dépenses nous alors ça c'est une
fonction mathématique très très simple
on additionne nos coûts et nos coûts
évidemment ce train de regarder un
rendement garder un rendement c'est ça
pour envoyer de l'argent à québec
absolument on est en notre actionnaire
principal c'est gouvernement du québec
alors on verse un dividende important
ce 19e se rappeler des fois aussi qu'il
est redistribué parce qu'il va servir à
payer
l'infirmière des livres dans les écoles
etc le tout venant qui est très
important qu'on verse les tarifs ont
donc augmenté
mouais - tu face au lot important de
cette année mais dans les prochaines
années
c'est quoi les vos prévisions de hausse
de tarifs pour les gens cette première
question que les gens lui portent sur
cette question importante
notre souhait puis l'engagement j'ai
pris quand je suis rentré en poste c'est
de s'assurer qu'on allait suivre
avoir des croissance raisonnable des
augmentations de tarifs raisonnables aux
alentours de l'inflation alors ça c'est
important et l'électricité faut rappeler
historiquement on a réussi à faire ça si
vous retournez en 1963 vous prenez 100 $
d'électricité
aujourd'hui ce sens dans la lave à peu
près 7 50 et le suivi parfaitement
l'inflation le gaz naturel est à 1500 et
le mazout le pétrole est à 2005 alors on
ne réussit à suivre l'inflation normale
pendant plusieurs un bon monsieur martel
vous êtes on produit trop d'électricité
pour la demande mais en même temps vous
êtes prick des contrats article 2 jours
encore vous payez pour un milliard de
dollars parce que vous êtes prêt que des
contrats qui ont été signés avant chez
les petits producteurs les éoliennes qui
tourne un peu pour rien est ce que c'est
un milliard conjointes d'un loup c'est
gaspiller ses prévisions là quand je
disais tantôt c'est du long terme
quand ils ont été faites au début des
années 2000 parlement on le dit on a
besoin de croissance alors faut acheter
les crises qui faisait le plein sens
d'acheter de l'énergie au lien ce moment
là parce que c'était compétitive versus
construire un nouveau barrage
et là il est arrivé ce que je dise on
avait des contrats des obligations ferme
alors là on est en ville ce sont les
rues avec ses contrôles mais ce qui est
important mais c'est ducati on achève
les titres et dont on n'a pas besoin on
ne gaspille pas parce qu'on ramasse
l'eau dans les barrages on essaie de
l'exporter rapidement et d'ailleurs pour
ça que dans la stratégie on regarde des
moyens de croire qu'on va construire des
routes pour accélérer l'exportation vers
les états unis
et on va se donner des moyens d'utiliser
cette énergie efficacement mais juste
peut-être un dernier point là dessus ce
qui est important pour nous c'est de
s'assurer qu'à long terme les prévisions
des nouvelles prévisions qu'on fait
qu'on va pas se mettre dans cette
situation alors ça serait très peu
probable qu'on donne un langage peu plus
vous n'êtes pas nié que ses contrôleurs
quand il signe et on ne sait sur pull et
le gouvernement voulait pousser l'éolien
l'époque pour créer des jobs n'était pas
économiquement la sphère la plus logique
il y avait une bonne raison pour le
faire dans une situation ce qu'on avait
de la croissance alors ce qui est
important c'est d'acheter quelque chose
qu'on a besoin non seulement cette
situation ce qu'ont dit nos prévisions
étaient pas juste on n'a pas besoin moi
dans le futur on va s'assurer qu'on
achète ce qu'on a besoin dit il faut
exporter
là il ya la nouvelle angleterre vous
êtes en lice pour un très gros contre
absolument new york
on veut continuer avant l'ontario donc
ça va prendre plus de ces lignes nous
faut de la sortie l'électricité
absolument comment on fait c'est quoi
votre plan puisque les gens sont prêts à
voir plus de pilon plus de lait dans la
stratégie de croissance ont un plan
précis sur lesquels on travaille
présentement on travaille avec l'ontario
au travail avec le new york la nouvelle
angleterre pour amener plus d'autos
d'autoroute pour l'électricité je
pourrais dire vers le sud ouvert vers
l'ouest pour vendre au surplus d'énergie
alors on en a on n'a pas suffisamment de
puissance au québec on a des
restrictions puissance à des moments
points mais par contre de l'énergie à
plusieurs mois dans journée concurrents
alors notre stratégie c'est que on est
très très proche de la nouvelle
angleterre très très proche de new york
alors moi j'ai eu plusieurs discussions
déjà depuis mon arrivée ericsson en 90
jours avec des partenaires américains en
ontario pour voir comment ça tout ça
peut prendre forme alors l'oeil on doit
procéder rapidement il faut construire
ces autos motos ça prend quand même
quelques années mais rapidement ça nous
donne une belle opportunité pour y fixer
quoi donner un peu plus de détails là
comme si le gros contrats étaient signés
avec la nouvelle angleterre
notre interconnexion notre ligne va être
près de caen en 2019
en 2019 ont commencé à exporter de
l'énergie dont on parle d'environ quatre
heures et est ce que vous voulez aussi
par exemple racheter des réseaux dans
d'autres pays
hydro québec international ça déjà été
important reliant le plus moi c'est
clair que mc mon constat quand j'arrive
en poste si hydro-québec veut continuer
de garder les tarifs les plus bas en
amérique du nord et veut continuer de
livrer un dividende ans qui est
important pour la nation est la vache à
lait du gouvernement c'est clair qu'on
contribue de façon importante alors on
doit s'assurer de croire d'hydro-québec
ont des moyens on vient d'en parler
c'est l'exportation l'autre
ça serait une expansion à
l'international exemple le jet est
propriétaire du réseau électrique au
chili on a très bien fait on leur remise
en ordre leurs vendus en effet un groupe
profite d'ailleurs quand on le vend du
prêt d'un milliard de dollars à l'époque
tout le monde au québec étaient contents
du sommet c'est des choses qu'on
pourrait faire pour aider là parce que
vous est ce qu'une logique ils nous
disent qu'ils aient des vous visez
d'acheter des réseaux actuellement à
l'étranger
présentement les portes du launay dans
une analyse la de définir les critères
qu'est ce qui pourrait être une cible
pour nous d'achat alors l'on est là
dessus il est en train de regarder un
peu un échange à faire un
échantillonnage certains cendres on se
limite pas trop présentement mais on a
des critères aussi que sont importe que
l'on pourrait devenir redevenir proprio
au point quelque chose qu'on considère
dans notre nouvelle est arrivée en poste
à 90 jours j'avais dit la transparence
est important qu'est ce qui a changé
et qu'est ce qui va changer parce que
souvent on vous reprocher draw québec
quand ça va pas bien
depuis personne pour vous parler
c'est l'état dans l'état j'avais
beaucoup entendu parler qu'est ce que
concrètement vous allez faire c'est
traître est là depuis mon arrivée que
j'ai travaillé avec l'équipe alors dire
qu'il a donné des noms aussi pris des
consignes des nouvelles consignes
exemple sont des demandes d'information
notre intention c'est toujours de dire
oui et de donner l'information ça peut
arriver dans l'eau des restrictions
c'est nouveau on appris ça il ya
quelques quelques mois à mon arrivée on
est seul on a seulement c'est vrai on va
vous rappeler quand ça va mal on va être
là pour répondre aux questions c'est le
temps le plus important pour hydro
québec de sortir
ok delà des questions difficiles et
c'est d'après moi une des pires choses
qu'on pourrait faire des gros québec
c'est de se cacher de cesser de répondre
alors on va lui sur la place publique
ça fait partie de mon mandat moi je vais
faire ça avec mon équipe et on va
répondre aux questions et on veut être
transparents on veut taxer ces bons vins
l'on veut expliquer notre compagnie est
excellent service à la clientèle
vous avez dit que c'est une de vos
priorités temps d'attendre pour les gens
qui vous appelle les gens qui veulent se
débrancher se brancher encore il ya
beaucoup de gens qui se plaignent c'est
quoi votre stratégie que j'allais depuis
mon arrivée j'ai passé beaucoup de temps
avec mes jean exemple au centre d'appels
on s'est posé la question pourquoi ça
prend du temps certains moments dans la
journée que quelqu'un va attendre trente
30 c'est inacceptable alors pour moi là
c'est on doit faire quelque chose pour
changer ça on est en train de revoir
comment on va organiser leur travail
comment voir on veut simplifier les
choses comment on va mettre en ligne
plus de possibilités pour les clients
de même les gens qui nous écoutent
devons voir le changement quand ces
changements là commence à prendre forme
présentement on vient déjà de mettre en
ligne les nouveaux outils qui vont
permettre aux gens de faire des
transactions par humain pas besoin
d'appeler et c'est très populaire
il est très heureux de ça déjà les gens
là de bonnes générations et même
d'autres personnes s'y intéressent
beaucoup mais nous on veut s'assurer que
quand quelqu'un appelle hydro québec on
est efficace on répond rapidement on a
des gens compétents au bout du fil qui
vont répondre aux questions reliées aux
six ans les installations c'est un autre
point important où on était critiquée on
veut s'assurer que quand quelqu'un dit
moi je vais déplacer mon poteau pour
installer mon nouveau cabano
bonsoir rapide pour interviennent
rapidement et qu'on sera capable d'être
précis le temps file comme l'eau ce
martel reste très rapidement des petites
questions en rafale
est-ce que les bornes pour les voitures
électriques
il y en a combien d'abord puis on verra
combien dans un an dans deux ans note
490 de déployer dans tout le québec
alors on arrive à 500 bientôt à la fin
de l'an 2016 donc très bientôt dans un
an et demi environ même pas un ennemi un
peu plus d'un an on va en avoir huit
cents alors nous on suit la cadence à le
parc automobile et rendent à 7000
voitures et on accélère dans les
priorités ou c'est quelque chose qu'on
fait un petit peu pour nous c'est une
priorité nous on s'assure que ça ne
devienne pas un empêchement pour la
croissance du parc automobile vérité
tous les québécois doivent payer la
facture diderot qui appelle poliment
ils sont coupés d'accord est ce que ça
vous allez revoir la façon dont on
traite les gens est ce que la façon dont
les copé écrit
hydro québec on doit définir l'an passé
on a eu 288000 ententes de paiement avec
vos clients alors c'était dans mes
clients avec certains six ans les coupés
sans les couper nécessairement y en a
aussi qui ont été pris alors c'est très
très clair avant d'avoir depuis les
pistes et les gens plusieurs
avertissements et on s'assure de leur
donner tout le temps pour faire des
ententes de paiement alors on essaie
d'éviter seul poste j'ai reçu un email
autrefois quelqu'un faisait pourquoi
nous ont su couper campé par les
autochtones seront pas coupés c'est des
citoyens sont québec la même là tu es au
travail les autochtones c'est un
partenaire extrêmement important pour
hydro québec je peux vous dire qu'on
travaille avec eux on essaie toujours
d'appliquer les mêmes règles si tu
n'aimes aimerait monter les règles des
fois lors il faut faire attention à
céder les peuples autochtones sont un
partenaire extrêmement important hydro
québec on et douvres j'ai manqué de
rythme les gens mais j'ai très prudent
la loose ou martin a patiné mais un
client qui paye pas devrait traiter
pareil hockey bauer puis avec les
autochtones à cause qu'il ya d'autres
ententes aussi qui peuvent influencer
sort on doit les approcher ils doivent
comme tout le monde mais aussi payer
leur compte alors à la fin ça nous est
déjà arrivé de faire des coupures et on
va continuer d'assurer de maximiser les
crémants qui viennent vergine demarthon
va se réparer merci merci monsieur roy
sont brisés a bien joué